it is the most unnerving thing on earth
yeah yeah it's like he's a robot and
somebody just taught him how to laugh
yesterday
bro that's exactly how he laughs
looks like yo who taught this dude how
to laugh have you ever seen him on the
roast where he does the coffee central
yeah i'm like it made me uncomfortable
watching him laugh like that
i was like are you seven years old dude
but please don't kill me
amy schumer's a electric [ __ ]
he's like literally slapping his knee
for like 15 minutes
when you listen to the the interview
with him on joe rogan's podcast
probably the most unnerving unnerving
thing he said was
so what do you call it when you get when
you when you have an erect an erection
oh yes
in five four three two
one me how oh wow uh-huh oh
nihow sir for sir first session
i was here
how [ __ ] dare you right now that was
rude you just said [ __ ] you in mandarin
dude yeah
wow do you think that's what our
language is
this is ridiculous
do you know do you know any mandarin i i
know what you said at the beginning
say your middle name what'd i say you
said dogs are brown wow that's pretty
good
yeah how do you say your middle name uh
the dope way
the dope way the real way the real way
see that's the thing it's like i
i i can't even say my name though shut
up and say your name
what's your middle name we already been
done this week man done
oh dude you're joking it is your real
name is ingook
yeah no like [ __ ] yeah i know yes
the racial slur for koreans yes yeah wow
so
you might be the googie's man of ours so
my brother's name is
my name is my cousin's name is hongguk
their kid his name is choguk and then
what does gay sake mean
huh kezeki well gaeseki means gay baby
[Laughter]
means [ __ ] it means like son of a dog
or
means like you [ __ ] [ __ ] okay yeah
you guys speak something
that i do in high school all the time
right here like she's a kesaki and i'd
be like what and then somebody told me
that means [ __ ]
culture dude and i was like yeah
cultured and then does sajah must mean
something or something which one sajima
or some [ __ ] that sounds like something
but i don't know what it is i i i
someone told me it means orgy but i'm
not sure
i don't know the word for orgy so it
could be it okay i don't know yeah i
just know the word
what kind
or you want to talk about private parts
you say koshigi which is
japanese and korean is very phonetic
there's no there's no uh tones right so
when you
listen to vietnamese chinese or any type
of chinese language whether it's
mandarin
taiwanese mandarin or cantonese it's all
[ __ ] tones
so it's it's kind of hard it's actually
really
easy to learn to speak the language but
it's hard to pronounce it
right so there's a lot of generalities
in language i only know this because i
try to learn vietnamese
so there's like words there's formal and
informal which is
the hard part right and then depending
on who you say and how old they are
you have to say it differently that's
really important how old they are
yeah oh so it's like formal there's
formal there's informal
status you know like kind of like that
yeah you know [ __ ] like that haunted
house
status but english is very hard to learn
because it's it's
too particular and very specific so like
in like i don't know like in
any asian language right it could be a
word for
that this that thing over there blah
blah blah anything in general that
points
an object over there is one word there's
no that this there
then none of that [ __ ] there's one word
for it so that's why the language is
easy to learn
but languages like you know spanish and
english is a lot more like
uh what's it called what are the
anglo-saxon languages they're very
particular in how you say those things
yeah that is true yeah
because like there's a linguist right
now that hates me they go that is
completely wrong
because even like understanding what
like prepositions were and like
understanding grammar
i don't know what a proposition is hard
it doesn't really stick with you
because you don't really need to like i
don't know that unless you major in
english
well i remember a school of rock and
that's basically yeah conjunction [ __ ]
just
i don't know i don't even remember
what's your fault
i never saw that until i was in like
seventh or eighth grade people was like
one step away from shooting himself in
the paper yeah
yeah he was sad that's the only thing i
remember is the bill part i don't
remember anything else from that video
the
top favorite kid shows top favorite kids
shows sesame street is one for sure for
me
so so like like really young like super
young okay
sesame street the sesame street was dope
and
reading rainbow reading rainbow oh i
started rainbow in school for some
reason like when the teacher would play
like like videotapes that's
a wishbone you remember wishbone
i always tell people about wishbone and
everyone's like nobody knows what's
going on
he would be solving mysteries dude i
know dude because there's a hat and [ __ ]
i usually go to this coffee shop in
sierra madre and like literally
it had the lighting of wishbone and i
was always like i always described you
like that i was like that place
literally feels like i'm in an episode
of wishbone be like
the [ __ ] wishbone i'm like get the
[ __ ] out of my face
and this is why he always punches people
in the face because it's something as
simple as a story of wishbones
and it just cracks them in the face
without explanation how do you guys not
remember wishbone but
i'm so happy that you guys know it yeah
the jack russell terrier yeah
jackross of terry and he talked and [ __ ]
wishbone was great he went back and
stopped
had a piece of chocolate now he died
oh that's how the series ended
yeah he went black like the surprise
yeah
that's exactly but uh reading rainbow
was one of my favorite shows
and uh also sesame street sesame street
was dope
had the green homeless man the large
pigeon and then the uh
the brown garbage that what was that
who's the brother
i like the muppets did you watch the
muppets no i didn't i [ __ ] with the
muppets
[Music]
did you guys ever figure out the how odd
it was that every person on that show
based on their ethnicity was the color
of their power ranger i didn't even
notice that
i didn't realize that until i got older
the black ranger was the black guy
was the black guy was the blue guy
because he was really sad
he was the black guy racial injustice
i'm blue the yellow
ranger was the the asian girl uh she
actually passed away did you know
in a car accident i had no idea yeah i
was making sure you didn't activate your
powers fast enough
[Applause]
take the episode yeah check that out
reference that one before you watch this
one thank you
but what i'm saying is oh and the red
ranger was a redneck
so there you go he was like he was was
he like mexican or something
he was like mixed mexican what's a
mexican
wasn't he mexican hey don't flip this on
me dude yeah
what's a mexican what is that
can i phone a friend about that one
mexican is hey
we just just passed away oh dude how
could no one talked about that regis
filming
he was dope too he was just philbin yeah
filming
phil philbin philbin he'd be filming all
kinds of
[ __ ] let's do this for an hour when you
say
the lesser i am
who was his first
[Laughter]
who was his first co-host it was it
wasn't kelly
host no it wasn't
mundane [ __ ] right i saw a young photo
of regis philbin he's a dime piece huh
no he looks like
he looked 80 when he was 20. so he's
like morgan freeman yeah you see a old
picture of
morgan freeman yeah but morgan freeman
looks like he was [ __ ] like the whole
time you know but like
he would be funny he just looked like he
was struggling a little bit when i was
in the [ __ ] it was fascinating
that's who got me too too people don't
talk about that oh he did
morgan freeman got me tools but he
apologized and then it was like did he
apologize
oh i thought you said somebody uh raped
him no no he
got accused he got accused
i was with you when we were reading that
we were a costume pie i don't listen to
you ever though but
what happened he just was saying like i
guess he made he made a comment about it
pregnant
it was like one this is one of them
there was like multiple ones
no he said he's like you're looking
right he says something like that that's
hilarious
you know come on it's semantics whatever
what are you gonna do
but you complain about him he's talking
about her like she's a fruit that's yeah
yeah there was some other stuff he got
in trouble for but he was just like i'm
sorry and then we're like all right it's
all good and then
he's good yeah he's cool because he
didn't touch them and i think he just
said some off-colored stuff because back
in the day
he could say that guys just said [ __ ]
like that and it was considered okay
yeah it was just yeah who knows i mean
who knows the context too
i mean it's morgan freeman bro he's
gonna be fine he'd be all right no one's
getting mad at that shawshank redemption
yeah dude he has the movies of [ __ ]
he has the most soothing voice of all
time march of the penguins
he's like the black monopoly dude
like i feel like if the monopoly dude
was black it would be morgan freeman
well god
has a monocle and [ __ ] i don't know why
i just got already got him but he has
like four thousand freckles and bumps on
his face
you can see gonorrhoeae got him that's
what god
does
yeah a man has braille on his face now
it's just nuts it
got worse as he got older huh i know
what is that what is that about i don't
know it's some kind of disease
i think so cool we're doctors by the way
yeah yeah he's half rock
you know what you know how people are
writing you know people are writing
their their like
they're questions about like their life
and that they go through on this podcast
so you should send us your health
problems like like oh i have these
symptoms and then we'll try to like
guess it on air
next question there it's always gonna be
that's the same [ __ ] webmd
says for anything you look like i can't
go without cancer hey i scraped my knee
hey guess what you have aids
you have coronavirus yeah yeah you got a
runny nose coronavirus
you have you have allergies from all the
fires in the area corona
remember when corona started and uh
everybody
was freaked out about their groceries so
they would leave it out on their porch
for three hours
oh so like that would be like ridiculous
yeah so there was a video
i i don't think it was fouchy but it was
another epidemiologist
right oh that was nice you said that
really nicely yeah i always stutter i
just floated
epidemiology yeah it was another
epidemiologist oh wow
i was born in shawshank that uh
he did a whole video talking about how
long the virus will last on a surface
and so that
that number changed so much it went from
a couple of hours to a to a few more
hours to a few days to like a couple of
weeks
but this jackass jack ass
i was going to say mother someone i'll
call him a jackfruit for some reason
[ __ ] jackfruit [ __ ] yeah but
this jackfruit eating [ __ ] said
that you should leave your you should
leave your groceries out there for like
three days
i was like who the [ __ ] is gonna leave
their groceries outside for three days
and not have it stolen i'll risk it rot
or yeah it's gonna go bad it was the
most ridiculous [ __ ] that he was
suggesting people do but people were
doing it because i remember when i was
walking around pasadena
people i just saw people's groceries
outside of the door you're like why are
they doing that and like i could use
some gummy bears i didn't pay for my
groceries for a whole month
it was nice it was gross celery i like
celery it was oh look at this it's
halloween don't mind if i do
like the drinking bleach thing do you
think people really drink bleach yeah
some people did
yesterday before that even happened
people were just eating tide pods do you
remember that yeah
yeah do you remember that it was like
crazy there wasn't even corona virus it
was just like
it's just because let's just eat that
actually is the cause of chronovirus it
was like a vine challenge or something
like that people were doing this
what the [ __ ] is that bro i don't know
how expensive tide pods are they're
pretty expensive they're pricey
oh did you get the costco one though no
dog the costco detergent ones number one
smell way better than the tide pods this
is how you know you're cold as [ __ ]
this is what we talk about we talk about
last time we ate together we sat down
and we talked for 40 minutes about
groceries like oh we got to go
through this side this is how old we
[ __ ] are this is what we talk about
and how did that change your life i
changed you changed it
for the better groceries
this is a hot take right now this is
gonna be a super hot take i might get
canceled for it
but groceries they're pretty pretty
[ __ ] dope and dope dude
hey man i like when i found those
kirkland tide pods i found out they were
way less they were way
do you work for costco or something i
know for reals yeah
he's like
that they had there is [ __ ] amazing
oh yeah yep oh
my gosh delicious their their meat is
the [ __ ] best it is it is and by the
way
dino nuggets if you want to be a good
father get yourself a nice costco box of
dino nuggets yeah
delicious i actually had it before i
came here compliments to the show
you're like every time you ate when
you're like thanks dad
it's so [ __ ] good it's a huge but
it's like a box that'll last you
maybe two months and it's uh thirteen
dollars
jesus yo chicken bakes remember chicken
bakes chicken bakes fire
come on what are the i don't i don't
know what chicken bakes are you gonna
have chicken bacon i don't know what
that is what the [ __ ] do you know
happiness how do you not know what
chicken what is a chicken
bacon it's just like a it's like a puff
pastry it's not a puff paste no it's the
same dough that they use for their pizza
oh okay so it's pretty much a hot pocket
but just way better
with chicken with chicken cheese
broccoli all that other stuff
nice
this podcast is brought to you by
bartleby
learn listen if you are out there right
now and you're a student
you need to get this how many of y'all
need help with your homework and there
is no
one to be found how many of you are
parents
that are dumb as rocks and you know for
a fact that when your kids ask you for
help on their homework
their [ __ ] out of luck this is where
bartleby learn
comes in this is a monthly homework help
subscription service for
just 9.99 a month that is a godsend for
students with bartleby you get millions
of step-by-step textbook solutions
30 homework questions per month a
subject matter expert with advanced
degrees to help provide support day or
night
and a searchable database of solutions
to homework questions asked by students
you also get homework help in more than
30 subjects including business
science math and engineering and receive
a detailed explanation to your questions
within one hour for my genius brain
listeners i got a deal to get you
started get 10 free homework questions
for 30 days
and sign up by just going to get
bartleby.com
brain that's get be a r
t l e b y dot com slash brain
to get this offer today response times
may vary by subject and question
bacon yeah
delicious the whole time you're eating
well that's the whole time you're eating
because you're just so hot
the whole [ __ ] time dude i can't
believe you've never had a chicken
never even heard of chicken bakes did
you ever go to the costco food court
area i've literally
i've never been to costco i've been in
costco like once in my life and i don't
know
i honestly don't know how i got in i
don't i think i snuck in i don't i
i just walked out of trying samples i
don't remember how i got past the
security bro
more intense than the [ __ ] border bro
costco food is [ __ ] cheap too by the
way you can get a hot dog and a drink
i'm talking a thick ass polish [ __ ]
bbc hot dog
wait what is bbc stanford a big black
[ __ ] okay bbc hot dog
for a dollar fifty for that and a large
drink
wow see but doesn't that make you wonder
like how are they doing this so cheap
because they make it dude you put bbc in
anything i'm in bro
it's not making it it's the hot dog that
they sell at the store so some dude in
the back is making it right there i
think
he's making the mold of his dick which
is the hot dog
cranks it out yeah so it's all their own
stuff they're not sourcing out anything
they make every like kirkland the vodka
they make shirts too
if you make tea you can't make vodka bro
how [ __ ] dare you isn't it they're
like branded
too their meat is like they're meat oh
they said meat i don't know
meat but they have like their own stuff
like their meat is their [ __ ] they have
like they have like bone broth i heard
their bone broth
it's probably the best bone broth for
the value on the market bro they make
everything
yeah who are these people so i don't
know kirkland is a city james
seattle or washington in washington i
think oh is that what it is like
kirkland washington or some [ __ ] like
that
yeah it's this christian dude just
wanting to help people out and convert
people
to christian judaism he's like drink my
vodka now
now yeah wow yeah all their stuff is the
best their fruit is the best their
produce is the [ __ ] they're watering
they're gonna take over the world but
that's the illuminati right there oh
the illuminati is kirkland bro because
they're making too many [ __ ] things
that don't make sense
you can i can have a factory that makes
shirts and vodka like that's weird
shirts vodka and shoes uh pens pencils
anything you can think of
but he gets it for a very affordable
price how how do you do that how do you
do
everything i think what i read online
was that they actually
don't make profit off of their stuff
they make profit off of the membership
so you get
a costco membership for whatever 99 for
a whole year that's where the profits
come in oh
yeah they're like a cooler version of
amazon well like they're there with
amazon first
four of amazon yeah because
costco employees too actually make uh
a good decent living really their
minimum their minimum pay is super
[ __ ] high so my my best friend
uh worked at a costco during college and
he was working there part time and he
was making [ __ ] good ass money dude
yeah yeah i remember i got a job back
costco i heard it's very hard to get in
huh
yeah it's actually not that easy to get
that job because they want some top-tier
ass workers
crazy yeah so you gotta be dedicated to
the game bro i remember uh my buddy used
to work there and then at the time i
i stopped talking to my parents i got
kicked out of their house so i had to
live with him at his apartment out in
davis while he was going to college
and uh this one time because i just
started getting the cooking at the time
i was like hey bro
just like a housewife from like the
1960s
i said hey i'm gonna make dinner make
sure you come back home on time because
the food's gonna be ready
and this [ __ ] came three hours
late
and his food was cold i was pissed
for him huh i made a delicious tilapia
wow and a rice
and a rice pilaf he said he said tilapia
he's like i'm gonna be late
he's a tilapia tilapia because at the
time he's trying to be healthy
i made a tilapia and a rice pilaf and a
vegetable medley
wow and it was three hours late i had
one
dim light bulb above my head with my
legs crossed like this and i said
well i hope it was worth it nobody gave
it he was like your food's in the oven
and he was like my bad bro i came super
late i was like yeah well guess what
you're not having dinner i took his
plate and i threw in the garbage can
nice
you showed him who's boss and then i
sucked his dick
yeah i like that that's dope i
appreciate that you said vegetable
medley yes i like just one vegetable it
was a medley of pepsi cans
is that a vegetable medley we got an
assortment of pepsi cans here it's just
like
two cans of pepsi yeah an assortment of
pepsi flavors there's one pepsi nick
there's only one pepsi you stupid son of
a [ __ ]
nick is the worst vlogger i've ever seen
in my life dude is hard bro
nick talks like this and then he starts
vlogging he's like hey guys so now we're
in the room and we're talking and we got
china
i'm talking to cadence like this and i
keep talking about like this that's how
i that's my vlog voice
vlogging is hard i don't know how people
do this for a living did you have a
[ __ ] ex-girlfriend that started
vlogging yeah i hated it
that's actually why we broke up yes well
i thought it was so annoying but i was
like with her so i was like all right
you know you got to support people is it
because she was bad at it
i mean no technically she was like if
we're if we're going to go break down
the craft of it she's doing it right i
mean it's just kind of like we'd be
sitting here like this
and then she'd be like now i'm gonna
make pancakes and i'd be like
uh what and also for who who am i
talking to yeah what is this they're one
of the most
i don't say the most [ __ ] up thing
i've ever did but sometimes you know
what
we're friends here right and we rag on
each other yeah yeah but sometimes i
i forget that uh the i have to be
mindful of who i do it to
so a buddy of mine he was on can i say
something real quick yeah
david always has a story about how he is
himself
around like friends or other people and
he always offends them
just by being him and he's usually there
to witness it
uh so you know when uh the instagram
live options started coming on
so when instagram live came out it was
made for people who are
influencers people who are people who
follow them right
so one of my friends decides to go on
instagram live and i just happen to be
on at night
right and he has like 60 followers and
he goes up
and he's like hey what's up guys so i'm
just gonna start making dinner right now
and i went on i said turn this [ __ ] off
you're embarrassing yourself
that he gets right off and he texts him
he goes hey bro i'm just trying to
[ __ ] start some new [ __ ]
i was like bro you have like 60
followers
i'm one of them yeah who's guys
he hasn't talked to me since he was
pissed wow i think
i heard his pride or something
a few years back is when instagram live
just started
so and at the time instagram live was so
weird
yeah it was weird that even influencers
didn't want to do it so it's so odd dude
i still feel like it's weird
i feel like there's like very few amount
of people that could do it really really
well i hate it when i'm like trying to
click on something and somebody
[ __ ] just started live and then you
hit it and then you're listening and
you're like no
but they see you it's especially curly
jordan then now they're gonna go hey
what's up pat
oh you're like being here for [ __ ] a
minute and act like i wanted to see
and be like hey dude and then i'm out
you know it's a whole bunch of what the
[ __ ] is this so the purpose of instagram
live is to connect with your followers
and 100 percent
right that's what it is right
that's what it is the timing of the
roast was
excellent yeah the purpose of instagram
live is connect with your followers and
have a good to create a following
and more one-on-one time with your
followers
about the pop-up i really do love you
dude
hey dude no i want you guys to [ __ ] on
me this is how this is how it always is
dude
right crickets
[Laughter]
wait don't you guys do this with your
friends all the time i want you to go on
instagram live so i could just write
you should please go on instagram
embarrassing yourself turn this off
yeah that's what i'm going to do i'm
going to start going instagram live now
so if i go on instagram live you know
why
because i want david to but it's a good
way to connect people but fans really do
enjoy it because
that's like the most personal
interaction that they can how many times
do you do instagram
i've probably done it about 10 times my
whole life do you like it uh i want to
say
i dislike it but it's definitely there
for what it is right so
i if i have a moment where i'm like yeah
i should probably thank these people for
supporting me
then i'll do it but it's it's hard like
i i i'm not very good at it like other
people i see other people on their
instagram live they're just
they're just talking out the butthole is
that a phrase yeah that's difference
yeah there's more specific things
all right they're just talking about
they're calling dude it's [ __ ] nuts
yeah yeah yeah without the sphincter
small intestine i feel like it's good
probably for like long drives if you
have like a long commute and you just
throw that on you just feel like you're
having a conversation with people
majority of the time when i do instagram
live is if i put
hook it up to the car mount and i don't
look at it and i just talk yeah
yeah it's pretty cool it seems kind of
dangerous but whatever but i said i
don't look at it yeah and i was like
i don't look at it i look forward you
know what's dangerous driving a miata
that has one of these
hey man like coma ass [ __ ] headlights
that sees nothing at night
okay do i almost die every time i drive
in that car yes
and that's all i'll say about it yeah
because that car is very small and if
if if someone on a bike hits me i'm in
danger yep
so it's not terrible not all of us can
have a forerunner i actually re-parked
his car for him outside by lifting it
with my bare hands he just moved it he
just pushed it over like excuse me
you just kicked it yeah dude my car's
fine tyson baby
who cannot wait for mike tyson to go
ahead and start sucking people out dude
i'm so excited mike tyson's scary as
[ __ ] have you heard mike tyson laugh
it is the most unnerving thing on earth
yeah yeah it's like he's a robot and
somebody just taught him how to laugh
yesterday
bro that's exactly how he laughs
looks like yo who taught this dude how
to laugh have you ever seen him on the
roast where he does the conversation
yeah i'm like it made me uncomfortable
watching him laugh like that
i was like are you seven years old dude
but please don't kill me
amy schumer's the electric [ __ ] and
he's like
he's like literally slapping his knee
for like 15 minutes
when you listen to the the interview
with him on joe rogan's podcast
probably the most unnerving unnerving
thing he said was
so what do you call it what you get when
you when you have an erect an erection
oh yeah yeah he was like somebody yeah
he said something about like what do you
call it when you get an erection
when he hurt somebody yeah somebody was
like jordan was like i guess
like you're excited or something it's
called a murder boner that's what joe
rogan
should have said and he was like yeah
he really said that yeah thinking about
hurting people how do you how do you
feel
like the matchup between him and roy
jones jr i think roy
jones jr gets punched once it's lights
out
i kind of think that's what's gonna
happen too i i i don't know if it'll
happen right off the bat but i think
i think tyson's gonna gonna be
especially the way tyson is moving right
now
at that age it's really weird yeah how
do you move like that
he moves so good and also too roy jones
what was his last fight like two years
ago right yeah it wasn't that long ago
and
so he's been fighting so he's been
sustaining head trauma still
well into his and he got like shut out
too tyson hasn't fought in what a long
time i mean yeah he's older but he
that's a long layoff from that trauma so
yeah he'll have
i think more of a chin he feels like
fresher probably yeah
i almost got a chance to go and
see michael michael tyson mike tyson
mike
train nobody in the history of ever has
called him michael
i almost said michael jordan because
there's a picture of michael jordan i
want to go see michael t song
[Music]
well because [ __ ] you know gianni
right gianni
yes so he hit me up and he goes hey man
you'll play kickball
on thursday i say [ __ ] no dude i'm gonna
play kickball i have never been invited
to play kickball exactly
and then he goes and then he goes like
the following week he goes hey you wanna
play kickball in calabasas
i was like double [ __ ] no i was like
[ __ ] no then he forgot to mention that
mike tyson was there
then i see him that same day i was
supposed to i was he invited me to go
and i said [ __ ] no which i still stand
by
he's at mike tyson's like house his
garage
gym or whatever the [ __ ] and he's
hitting the bag and he's taking a
picture of mike tyson afterwards
and i was like dog i thought you're
gonna play kickball day he goes no i was
i'm gonna play kickball later but we
came to kick on mike tyson first
and i was like dude [ __ ] you why'd you
not want to play kickball though i feel
like that's part of your your program at
exercise science
yeah exercise science you actually
minored in that dude like i said i'm
trying to get away from the game a
little bit sometimes i need my weekends
to unwind and not
worry about like whistles and bouncing
red balls so i decided to take the day
off
and not play kickball okay and it cost
me what would you have said to mike
tyson nothing
i would have been so scared i would have
looked i would have been such a weirdo
it's better that i didn't go
so who who is this guy over here with
his small little eyes who is he
and i was just like can i just touch
your arms for a second don't touch me
like that you little [ __ ] sorry
and i'll be like and i only say that
because he has actually said that he
would say he's like oh [ __ ] you do you
love me
that's exactly what he said which is one
of the greatest quotes of combat history
ever you know what the the crazy thing
was when he had uh was it a sugar ray
leonard on his podcast
and he was talking about how it feels to
not be able to
fight or access his rage or or get into
a ring because he feels like he's a
gladiator and a warrior
and he starts bawling and crying talking
about he's because he goes i just feel
like a little [ __ ]
i'm like yo this guy's nuts that's how i
feel crazy
i love listening to him though because
like he'll come out with like these
little wise things and like
he'll be he's really wise and he'll say
certain like he'll put certain words
together we're like wow that was really
eloquent yeah
and it's like what the [ __ ] but then
he's also this crazy like a
yeah like a savage murderer [ __ ]
i think in prison he just read it
thesaurus all day
how long was he in prison for a few
years like i won't say four years five
years what do you go to prison for again
rape i think
oh yeah which i i
don't know i don't know i didn't think
you were gonna say that no but
all the things like because he's so
candid about everything i feel like
like he's candid about everything yeah
about like getting stds fighting in the
ring with stds doing drugs
[ __ ] being a dumb ass box what do you
have
he had uh for one of the fights i don't
know who he was fighting it wasn't
holyfield he fought somebody and he had
a
syphilis i think syphilis or gonorrhea
he had some uh terrible ones
he had a curable one but he fought with
it and was like taking the medication
and was like oh [ __ ] like this is whack
and then he goes out and knocks the dude
out
with a [ __ ] burning dick
but uh i don't know i don't know bro
that who knows
he would say something what did he say
about it has he ever talked about it
he's always claimed that he didn't do it
that's what i'm saying like he's very
candid but he always claims that the
reason
he calls them letrus [ __ ] wow he
called them electrous [ __ ]
like he would call the women who accuse
him of rape leches [ __ ]
what is that i don't even know what that
means that's what that's true seems like
lepers
like letters means like conniving or
some [ __ ] like that see
that dude did read that that's like a
medieval word
[ __ ] anglo-saxon bro are you a shame
spare me of your banalities you letras
[ __ ] yeah but exactly
wow dude you know what i mean
shakespeare or some [ __ ] yeah you know
what i'm saying i read
that's pretty good dude that's actually
really good dude sons of anarchy one
time i heard one of the
guys called a girl a devious gash and i
was like that's some shakespeare [ __ ]
too
he's like devious cash he was like got
betrayed by some girl
i was like no biker would ever be here
some british ass biker get the [ __ ] out
of here you devious gosh but that was a
good that was that was a mike tyson one
for sure
do mike tyson he has uh this really
funny documentary that's not supposed to
be funny
on netflix and it's the worst doc you
have ever seen
in your life and it's by this director
that's known to make terrible [ __ ] but
somehow he always gets funding
but i'll send you guys that link later
on you'll watch it you'll cry [ __ ]
laughing really
because it's kind of deep but they had
these really weird images of just mike
tyson by himself walking alone on a
beach
and him talking about these women he
goes these these let he call them
succubus
he goes these women are just a bunch of
electric horses they're sucky bits
it's like yo what the [ __ ] i was looking
at mike tyson yeah wow
thanks that's what i do he does it with
the list
so crazy mike tyson's such an anomaly
like that dude is a legit
like like a [ __ ] just murderer set
like
crazy [ __ ] people are just so
fascinated by him because he's so
like primal and everything he's
eccentric too there was that one sound
by where
they were like so mike how did you feel
about the fight i broke my
back yeah yeah like what spinal
like that's not what we had a question
about yeah my back finally
yes what does this guy say he's like is
he talking to me
that's what he's thinking about the
whole time dude he has some great rants
too
like the impregnable one where he's like
going off like i want to eat his
children my defense is impregnable
alexander the cockroach no i'm alexander
the conqueror like whoa this dude's
[ __ ] going off
i'm gonna fight him i'm gonna eat his
children after i give birth to his
children as a dookie i'm gonna put it
into a frame after that frame to collect
bacteria that bacteria is gonna live
very long it's turned to cover 19
it's going to devastate the world and
then i'm going to marry your mother
like wow he tied that off really well
and the fact that he bit some dude's ear
off
is like people kind of forget about that
oh yeah [ __ ] abandoned holyfield
like the fact that he did that in the
middle of the fight because he was mad
that he was like head butting over some
[ __ ] right
people his fighting style is just so odd
just because
so unique in the heavyweight division
well you know it was isn't he the
youngest person to ever win a heavy
heavyweight
yeah i think he's 21. i think he's young
he was a teenager he was like 19. oh
really
or maybe tigers and [ __ ] you know i mean
it's so crazy so fast he's such a
fascinating even his trainer custom
model is really dope too yeah
when you watch like the like i've seen
documentaries about their dynamic and
stuff and like
people talk about cuz i don't i don't
know anything about his trainer though
he was like a yoda he's like literally
like a yoda type dude
he shaped that just super yeah like he
used to like uh
he just he had him live with them and he
would he would fill him with his
philosophies and whatnot
and he was like he would hypnotize him
and like did like
hypnosis training like he was very like
mystic in a way
yeah it's sick when you get into it and
when you hear the way that dude talks
like he was just like a
not only was he an amazing uh boxing
mind but he was just amazing like about
the human mind in general
and then he had this this [ __ ] dude
mike tyson and he just molded him
to be this [ __ ] like he literally
would hypnotize mike tyson
sometimes he talks about it on certain
podcasts and he was like he would just
hypnotize me and like teach me to be
like a just
like a savage like destroy destroy
destroy so like not only are
is mike tyson already like that but now
in his subconscious it's like
destroyed and then because he died
without undoing his work
yeah right and that's what he was like
well that's that's the cool thing about
tyson is like whenever you hear
fighters talk they'll talk about like
their sport they'll talk about like
the art of boxing but very rarely do you
hear
like fighters talk about like the
mindset that it takes to become a
fighter and like
for combat in particular like overall
arching like
he's going to war that's how mike tyson
is thinking about it like
usually when you hear fighters talk like
yeah we're gonna go out there give it a
hundred ten percent you know like they
talk like athletes
yeah but this dude talks like he's a
general getting ready to [ __ ]
lead his troops in the battle and like
going into the battle of thermopylae
tomorrow yeah
because he's thinking like oh i'm gonna
go in there i'm gonna die
he's so interesting because when i saw
him box i i only realized recently that
nobody actually boxes like mike tyson no
no no
not the heavyweights because he's a
smaller guy and he had a [ __ ]
he had to get around that reach and it's
nuts his head movement is so
odd yeah just back and forth back and
forth back and forth in
doesn't really throw many he even his
jab and his straights are very off
they're off angle
they're never like directly there went
down the pipe it's off angle like this
it's so weird because i couldn't tell
the difference between his hooks and his
and his jabs and his crosses yeah but
they are jabs and crosses he just throws
them at a weird angle
yeah he has off center line yeah yeah
he's always moving that peekaboo style
hands up just
he was always he was good at changing
angles too like like
not only like he would hop around yeah
he would shift like he would go from
orthodox to southpaw
jumper like he would do it like a lot of
hops bang bang he was dude he was sick
as [ __ ]
he created this so amazing yeah who's
that guy they say that they call them
like uh they they always comment that
he's a young mike tyson but he's
he has a really bad record what's his
name again i don't know
i don't know who that is uh [ __ ]
wasn't he's the one that beats up his
kids on instagram oh james the pc yeah
james the beast wellston
yeah that [ __ ] is cute
he always beats the [ __ ] out of his kids
on his instagram it's [ __ ] hilarious
okay like he uh and he but he always
does inspirational quotes
okay on you gotta [ __ ] fight through
it
my kids are warriors and then he locates
low kicks his four-year-old
through the wall they're like eating
cheerios
you can't his kids are getting [ __ ] up
by it wow we used to train with that
full man he said beat us all up
that guy's big yeah he's big as [ __ ] man
huge
his record is not that great though
because i started reading a lot of the
comments under his post and people are
like well what's your [ __ ] next fight
when's your next fight when's your next
fight yeah and then because i don't
think he has been in a fight
that kind of just leads to a snowball of
negative comments so they're like oh you
think you're enticed but i don't think
he's ever said he with a tyson i think
that's what other people say about it
they just come probably yeah they're
probably just like this big dude
he's shorter than tyson though i mean
he's taller than tyson tyson's less than
six feet james is like he's like six
two maybe i think he's like six foot
six one he's he looks like he's like six
one or six two cause he's he's he's just
wide as [ __ ] like he's a refrigerator
bro yeah
he's biggest [ __ ] and he's scary but
he's a kick boxer
kickboxing yeah kickboxing yeah yeah
yeah
he's a kickboxer kickboxer you know he
come through here you hit him with a
punt right here and then they wake up
uh-oh
oh i don't i don't know he fought in
glory right
didn't he find glory glory yeah he
fought glory
glory glory it was glory i think oh he
found a glory kickboxing
it was in la it was la i remember that
fight we were all
we were all training at fight academy
together savant cornered him i remember
that
and he knocked the dude out he fell
through the ropes and that's when he
started gaining some momentum because
everybody was like yo
who the [ __ ] is this dude because you
look at him he's very marketable you
know what i mean
huge big giant dude ex-football player
athlete
jack the [ __ ] knocking people out dead
so you're like
jesus what are we what are we gonna do
with this [ __ ] guy then he went
took that match he started beating up
his kids he started shooting his kids
does he live in l.a
i think so okay uh oops
he's going to beat us but these are just
i'm just saying from what i saw from his
instagram i just saw this video of him
[ __ ] locating the [ __ ] out of this
kid it was hilarious
yeah and he there's this very famous
video of him making his kid punch
through a board
and the kid's crying because yeah yeah
that's right that's right yeah so he
hasn't featured him yeah dude they
people social media likes him you know
but at the same time
it's uh people want to see you fight
that's it yeah i don't i don't know what
you want to see
is he is he an active fighter i i don't
remember
i remember the last time he fought i
think to my knowledge
his his big kickboxing fight he fought
in france he fought this
other dude and akko cornered him i
remember
and that was maybe what 2015 2016. oh
damn it's been a hot minute then
he's not an active fighter then he maybe
he just trains nah you know i'm sure he
probably makes more money doing that on
instagram than
why aren't you doing that stuff dude
what beating up kids
i'll be up some kids i've got some
videos i've got some old videos yeah i
want to see you beating somebody
elementary schools and just start
[ __ ] i don't think i'm not i'm not
jacked enough for people to like be
impressed you're pretty joking bro
let me get [ __ ] i'm gonna i'm gonna
hop on some steroids dude i'm gonna do
some hgh what do you guys think about
that
growth hormone do you want the hgh gut
yeah dude i'll just
to stand out it'll be fine if i got 29
inch biceps baby
brother 29 inches yeah dude very large
it's very large
you can't even do an instagram post 29
inch biceps huh
yeah yeah with all the stories i'm gonna
do i'll be fine that'd be cool you
already [ __ ] useless
it's gonna it's gonna come on the
instagram i hate when he talks about
stuff that he's gonna do because it's
never gonna happen
yeah just i'll do some steroids yeah
yeah no you won't i gotta go
the other one sarms yeah i'll do some
swarms i'm really thinking about trying
out something let's let's do let's do it
let's
all disarm this is what you do before
you fight chris sosa sorry chris i love
you
you do some steroids too pat will do
some steroids and we'll just see
best man win what do you guys think we
just have a mutant fight yeah
you guys are all jacked as [ __ ] yeah
he's like
yo what's up pat [ __ ] you
and then you guys started yelling each
other but what is sarms i don't i what
is that
song is like it's like steroids but like
a lower level of it i guess it's not as
chill healthy version that's not healthy
but would you recommend it it's not as
strong
the question is should i take it or not
probably not do i actually have to work
out
and do it yeah for sure okay yeah here's
the thing when you do steroids you do
anything else it just allows you to
train more
and harder than if you weren't and just
your body's more anabolic meaning you're
more likely to grow some muscle because
i've heard some people take steroids and
they don't work out and they literally
just get big like they just get fat
they're just like
large but not muscular you gotta train
really [ __ ] hard too like
yeah you take steroids that's what a
buddy of ours found out i found out
about creatine back in the day when i
was it was a church guy and his name was
rich
so this dude rich started taking a bunch
of creatine and protein powders and [ __ ]
but he didn't know that you're supposed
to work out
that's supposed to help you in your
workout this fool got a hell of a
feeling like
when you look at mass gainers there's
like it's like 300 sometimes even 500
calories
per serving so you you drink two of
those a day
yo khalif used to take that [ __ ] he used
to take something called enormous
yeah it makes your ass [ __ ] it was
called enormously got a fat old
he would mix his shakes with uh olive
oil
like whole milk whoa and then a peanut
butter
and then each shake was i think he
spilled my water out like 200 calories
or something like that and he would take
that three times a day
jesus christ because he's one of those
dudes that burns so much his calories so
fast he gets skinny in a second yeah
so the moment he he got off that workout
regimen and that enormous stuff i think
he had the flu
so he couldn't do anything he lost like
20 pounds of muscles in like two weeks
for you to eat like more than you are
supposed to eat to try to gain muscle
it's like for you to bulk
it's hard you're not really [ __ ] hard
if you guys want to know how to gain
weight hit up your boy right here phd
but like eating with clean
healthier foods to eat that much is
really [ __ ] hard it's hard i had dino
nuggets today i wasn't supposed to have
it yeah
dino nuggets battle nuggets is the key
though
that's how you want to get big eat dino
nuggets have you ever seen dollars have
you guys heard of this uh
this is a side thing but the other day i
was gonna send you guys this [ __ ]
clip
but um it's three comics if i mentioned
there now i think you guys wouldn't know
who they are but there's this girl her
name is uh nicole arbour do you know who
she is
she she did this video that went super
viral called uh dear skinny people
and she would like basically
it was very conscious [ __ ] on a skinny
boy she's she uh no dear fat people
oh dear friends she's [ __ ] on fat people
she did another oh she does a lot of
weird like controversial stuff but
apparently she's like a canadian comic
is she like an aria shafir a female
archer fear style no because ari shafir
is
actually a decent comic he's just you
know weird but like so
nicole arbor so i did a parody of her
video a while ago called dear skinny
people
as a parody to that right did really
well not
whatever you know killed it so
you know she's been recently going she
recently like
maybe a few months ago went on a comedy
podcast with a bunch of other comics
and it was the worst thing i've ever
seen in my life
because so she did something
which is i think is a huge faux pas
right so she's known
she gained her notoriety through youtube
right um but because she did she did
like a laugh festival whatever
you know stand-up comic stuff which you
see her stand up it's not good at all
um but she did her stand up there but
she wants to be recognized for her
standup
so when they were interviewing her they
were asking her like okay so you got
recognized because you did you do these
youtube videos she goes i don't really
do youtube
wait i know who you know who she is she
does the [ __ ] ninja song
is that her does she does it i don't
know what that is oh
sorry i say i gotta i gotta have you
guys listen it's such an
awkward interaction because it's it's
them just asking questions about her
and her trajectory but the moment they
say that she's a youtuber she gets hyper
defensive she goes oh
i'm not a youtuber this is her
i was thinking about louis gomez she
wanted louis gomez's podcast okay
okay so you got to listen to this [ __ ]
and i was like we're considering
changing the name uh no you know arbor
fest
all right yeah i was mostly mad i'm like
oh this [ __ ] named this whole
podcast [ __ ] of me and my
college friends there's gotta be some ip
[ __ ] going on there
you're like a youtube star right or
something like that ish i'm just
comedian
and then is that tony hitch yeah cause
they wanted me to post videos on youtube
do you make money off of youtube i'm
doing good like i'm not a youtuber oh
that's a guy that does it with uh
michael's
comic for a very long time got in a bad
car accident so i couldn't do stand up
because i couldn't stand up
and then i was like well [ __ ] i can film
myself like this you just include one of
your jokes on the show just now
i didn't no no are you okay can i i'll
keep going okay
so i just like started filming my [ __ ]
but there's a thing like if someone says
you're like successful from youtube
where you get seemed to she did get
defensive oh i hate that you're like no
i'm like oh no
your drawing power comes directly from
youtube right
facebook more like facebook and
instagram more oh yeah
but you put a lot of a lot of the
stand-up content out this is hard
oh no actually honestly i used to be a
cheerleader for the toronto raptors like
actually for real as a cheerleader for
the toronto raptors and it was us
freaking sucked okay
and she said if she's freaking suck back
every girl that likes me acts like this
at first literally every [ __ ] girl
so i i just have to believe you i'm
sorry that i have to [ __ ] drag you
into reality that's your future look at
it no
i don't want to look at that what up
girl this is it where's my soul
this is [ __ ] happening this whole
thing hurts my soul a little you got
some success off youtube
and you don't want to be considered a
youtuber so now you're doing stand-up
shows
exclusively or you're still doing
youtube videos you are no i like
never really did youtube videos i just
threw my [ __ ] on youtube and facebook
which is doing youtube videos i don't
know why she's so defensive like what's
wrong with the [ __ ]
so that this this whole interview is
done that's right the hardest thing for
me to watch
right because and the reason why i don't
know why this popped up on my feed
but it came up and it just said you know
nicole arbor bombs i'm like bombs what
like
so she it's weird that she's saying like
oh i don't do youtube
she literally did youtube like did a
video a video every week
so i don't understand like there's
nothing wrong with doing youtube
you know like if you're funny you're
fine and also if you do youtube and
you're
trying to transition to a stand-up just
say that [ __ ] yeah so with her i
you know i understand what the stuff the
stuff that she's saying right now
because so when i first started doing uh
youtube back in the day right
i started off doing stand-up as a young
comic when i was like 16.
so because i started doing that i was
trying to hold on to this title of being
a stand-up comic that just does youtube
on the side yeah but mind you this was
10 11 years ago yeah right this was
this year you know yeah so the
the stigma of being a youtuber was
pretty bad when i first started okay
like comics would [ __ ] on me
they would say like oh you're just a
youtuber even though i've done stand-up
longer than they have you know yeah okay
but they didn't know that about me and
it didn't really matter and i took it
very negatively like
if i could give you an example one time
um i did this uh
this uh it was like uh it was basically
a variety show right but they had it was
just all comics right it was a bunch of
asian comics
and everybody was stand up comic and on
my title they put youtuber
and that [ __ ] pissed me off i remember
it pissed me off because it seemed very
deliberate
right and so these guys they're like oh
stand up comic stand comic stand at
comic and then i was one of the
headlines
and they just said youtuber even though
they knew i was going to do stand up
yeah so that's the type of
stuff that you know they would do that
type of stuff right right
they're talking [ __ ] i'm like all right
cool so i'm gonna go up and i'm a
[ __ ] kill on the set
i did really well on that set and after
that then the conversation shifted a
little bit exactly
like oh you know he actually does stand
up that's like but if you just had a
conversation with me you would have
known that
but they i think what happened was is
that those people were doing stand up
a lot longer than me in their mind and
they go well this young kid's coming up
and now why does he get to shine
yeah you know even though i'm a funnier
person so she's probably still in that
state but that's
a decade old now yeah youtube is
something that's very viable people use
youtube as a platform but nowadays it's
way more accepting
to like but there's no there's i mean i
can still i can still see look i mean
comics are going to [ __ ] like
this we talk [ __ ] you're shocked you're
around comics somebody's going to talk
[ __ ] to you that's just the nature of
the game so obviously they're going to
pick at
the youtube thing that right like
they're like ah you're not you don't
really do it
uh but that approach that approach of
like trying to avoid it
is the worst yeah it was the worst did
you just [ __ ] feel your whole body
just going down
ah that's the thing about bombing too is
like when you see somebody else bomb
like it hurts you too
it's like and she's going into a group
of three comics
and they're like calling her out about
it they're like yeah but just say it
three comments
and like aggressive like talk [ __ ]
comics you know like
dude that reminds me of thoughts bad
[ __ ] talks about that [ __ ] that reminds
me of uh
do you remember the show called tough
crowd with colin quinn yeah dude it was
a sh it was when i was growing up so it
was like kind of like podcast before
podcast con quinn used to have this show
on comedy central where
he'd have like patrice o'neill bill burr
kevin hart it was like all the goats
like greg
it's like before they were like oh
and there's one where um it's patrice
o'neill
and uh i there's this other white dude i
forgot his [ __ ] name but he's really
funny too
and then that fan is on there oh yeah
yeah just one
uh that show
dude that's bobby lee's best friend and
he was doing
like he was doing like the vietnamese
like he kept doing the vietnamese like
mom
and patrice o'neil just who was like the
master destroying people
just starts [ __ ] tearing him
apart like hard like oh you just do your
hacky vietnamese voice again like what
uh come on what else you got
like and it's like oh and then the other
guy i forgot his [ __ ] name
i hate it because he's the [ __ ] too but
he starts right on railing
and it's just all of them hitting him
like nothing and i mean yeah he was just
i mean what's he gonna do it's like that
but times
ten because they're like it's like not
only are they calling them out but
they're [ __ ] them up now yeah
in front of a crowd in front of the
crowd they were actually pretty nice
about it like tony hinchcliffe in them
like yeah it was awkward but they were
just kind of like come on like
they were trying to just be like come on
be honest let's move on from this
conversation right let's just just be
real like you do youtube it's fine like
blah blah
but like patrice and that other dude
went at him hard like it wasn't
billboard rich boss no it wasn't bobert
yeah richard
yeah i think there was another guest but
it was mainly rich foster patrice o'neil
and they
[ __ ] went hard dude and i was like i
remember watching him being like
this that was probably the only the the
downfall of his
[ __ ] career honestly after last comic
standing like
he because i remember when i was in
sixth grade my dad was like yo
watch this dude and we watched him
because at the time seeing an asian dude
on tv
that's not bobby lee at the time because
that was the only person we had i
remember
bobby lee and i remember i was like yo
this dude is because i was like sixth
grade i was like this guy's [ __ ]
hilarious you know
and then after he left the show
everybody realized he would do the same
[ __ ] stick over over and
over and over and it just like dude stop
like it's it's too much because like i'm
her margaret cho right
she's another like icon in the comedy
game she would have her asian accent
stuff too but like
it wasn't it's a story about her family
exactly
but then she had other jokes like right
like every bit that that fan would do
would always have an asian accent like a
vietnamese accent yeah
constantly and it was to the point where
like now when i rewatch it
now as an adult i can't even watch like
three like
30 seconds of it without going like oh
this is bad man it's really bad because
you can't you couldn't wait to just keep
talking about over and over and over
again but
but that's why he doesn't really do that
much comedy right now does he does he
he's still just comedy but i don't think
he just has the he hasn't had the name
anymore
anymore yeah but um yeah bro i i mean
dude comedy's [ __ ] hard
it's really hard it's so hard and uh and
sometimes people just catch you on a bad
day and that's
that's all you are is the [ __ ] coming
yeah yeah
honestly yeah i had a bad day like
michael richards just that remember what
dave chappelle said about that oh yeah
that's just a bad set
she just kept on saying like no i don't
i don't do youtube i actually do more
facebook then she started saying like
yeah
like all that like that's any better
yeah right you know like oh yeah i do
facebook videos you know like when
things are just people are trying to
move on from the subject then you go
like i was like oh are you
are you gonna make this awkward it's
like oh god yeah just don't don't do
this
don't do this but the thing is like just
[ __ ] accept it be like i'm a youtuber
and i'm
trying to transition to stand up you
know and they'll [ __ ] on you a little
bit but like there's some respect to be
gained by just being real just being
[ __ ] real and you know honestly too
it's like at that point
like you have to build like this
camaraderie with roasting too like if
they like you then you roast then you
could roast back yeah but when she was
trying to roast them there was no
camaraderie at that point because she
didn't
she wasn't being she was she was lying
she was lying she was lying yeah so at
that point there's there's no
there's no give and take yeah so she's a
comedian you know it's like so
so what was the video that she did about
her talking about she just did a lot of
controversial [ __ ] and then you know she
gained a lot of notoriety on youtube and
facebook because she would say stuff
that wasn't very popular and
i think when you say non-popular stuff
especially as a comic
if it's funny it's funny yeah right but
her stuff just wasn't that funny
listen to more of the [ __ ] it cuts
between things like themselves
just me talking to the cam for like a
couple minutes and then pop it up
and do my editing that's literally being
a youtuber yeah was doing some
live shows too and so many other things
that that's what i'm mostly going to be
doing
so where did you see him at this point
uh this guy doing stand-up
the i don't know the big comedy club in
austin cap city yes cap city
i love this conversation because i just
i love that comics because i came from
doing stand-up for like every year
she keeps bringing it out you know who's
really hot is your ex's new boyfriend
[Applause]
oh no that's that sure hurts my feelings
dude this makes me feel really
embarrassed
i'm good now i'm done we're done you
just came
now yep yes done we're even first time
that's ever happened for you do you have
a boyfriend nicole
maybe do you whoa she's one now you know
what it is
she doesn't want to say it because she
knows that'll [ __ ] she does have a
boyfriend here's what happened i know
exactly what happened
i know exactly too boyfriend will be mad
if she says no
yeah but um i think the only people that
follow you i'm just saying that
you have a you do have a dudley fan base
you don't actually it's 55
women hey analytics yeah that's true
that's what that's just
like everything she's saying isn't
defensive you probably have a big dude
fan base she goes actually don't i have
women who follow
it's like why even say that you're not
now it's not fun
right now you're just being combative
yeah it's just it's just it's weird now
yeah just be real you know because like
she would have gained way more respect
in that situation if she was just honest
and
like yeah like i'm a youtuber and like
you said fan base yeah mostly male
whatever blah blah blah they think i'm
hot
whatever the [ __ ] but i'm trying to i'm
trying to make this [ __ ] happen like
what's up you know
okay cool like how did you not respect
that and if i'm not like that respected
of a stand-up comic
i would be there to be like yo i'm in a
room with [ __ ] tony hinchcliffe yo
can you give me some tips bro yeah out
please
exactly like let me learn from you can
we like what do you got you know yeah
um it's like it's like she's doing that
i mean i'm not saying like dave
chappelle but like if i'm in a room with
dave chappelle i'm not going to sit here
and
try to go laugh for laughs with the with
the comments very well known
exactly and i forgot tony hinchcliffe's
name i'm so sorry and
and also to like try to establish
yourself like no i'm a co i'm i'm a
comic i'm a cop like [ __ ]
dude it's so embarrassing it's like you
don't you don't have to keep saying that
over and over and over and over again
yeah and that makes me feel like you're
not a stand-up comic
it's a very awkward thing so awkward and
i'm like yeah and then when she's like
oh yeah that big comedy club in
texas and he's like caps comedy
cap city yeah yeah he's like yeah like
everybody knows that like and you don't
even know that like yeah so it's like
you know and for her point too is it you
could just be somebody who gained
notoriety on youtube there's nothing
wrong with that
and say like but i came from stand-up
but then i got bigger on youtube and now
going back into stand-up
what is the problem why can't you say
that like right what does that mean
like well she was just so afraid of the
roast you know she was so afraid of
being like
like demonized that she was like all
sounds like she's not
a comic you know yeah that's like a very
uncommon thing to do but it's like
bro that's that's such the wrong
approach cause you could be a comic like
a funny person right
which the people can label that as a
comic but she's trying to go on to the
point of like i'm a stand-up comic
cool whatever yeah you know you know
yeah i mean and there's nothing wrong
with being honest about where you're at
like for me example like if i was like
yeah i'm a [ __ ] touring headliner
right now like i'm not
like i i like i've been doing it for
like six years i've gotten better but i
still got work to do like that's the
truth that's the truth like i've learned
some [ __ ] i can i can make [ __ ]
laugh i know i'm not gonna be
a complete ass up there now like i'm
somewhat comfortable but like i still
got a lot of room to grow like yeah
it's crazy for me to be like oh i should
be touring with [ __ ] dave chappelle
right now that would be
[ __ ] insane for me to say that you
should be but like
but you should supportive
hi my name is pat and i don't do [ __ ]
youtube and you're like whoa
this guy's throwing a thousand or
something dude you gotta watch the
patrice
o'neal one is so cause he like he was
so good at [ __ ] on people anyways
and then it's just like
it's just murder you know what the sad
thing is i found about found out about
patrice o'neil stand up too late so i
found out about his stand up
oh so i saw him on on the office i was
like oh yeah yeah
i started looking up the cast members i
found he did stand up and then i looked
at his old stand-up hilarious
[ __ ] like two years later he dies i'm
like yeah dude what the [ __ ]
that dude diabetes honestly he i think
i think he does go down as one of the
greats but like he if he was around
right now like he was
he would murder like he was bill burr i
think like
times 10 to be honest like i mean
billboards i love bill bird but like
[ __ ] patrice o'neill was so
goddamn good i the the one the reason
why i know the show that you're talking
about i saw the one with him and bob
saget and he was just [ __ ] on bob
sacks
yeah yeah
that show was i remember watching that
as a kid and i i
like i said we had the illegal box so i
i mean i was like
[ __ ] 10 at the time but i was like
this [ __ ] i just liked it for some
reason
but dude patrice kevin hart was on it uh
bobby
kelly and they would just have these
back and forth like just just
massive [ __ ] talking like they were like
pro [ __ ] talkers there was uh
uh the pg version of that on like public
television where there's that bald guy
that looks like keegan michael key the
black dude yeah
it was comics unleashed and what it was
or some [ __ ] but
it would what it was was like hey david
i heard you have a
you had a funny experience with your
korean grandmother why don't you tell us
about it yeah and he would pretty much
just set them up
and it'd just be just like oh dude this
is awful this is so terrible
it was always like it was always like 11
p.m on like
it was like 1am on like a saturday
morning at night like yeah
it was like the weirdest time i forgot
his name i want to say byron allen
was that his name that sounds like a
basketball player byron scott is a
basketball player yes i think it is
byron allen
okay let's look it up right look it up
well let's see what the prize that
you're gonna get
let's see here but um that show was
really bad
it was bad it was super bad you're right
byron allen yeah
suck my dick okay so my dick from the
back i was gonna do it either way
byron allen folks is an american
businessman comedian television producer
philanthropist and the head of u.s
entertainment company
allen media group that guy was for sure
clean 100 of the time oh a hundred
percent
always clean always clean comic the fact
that i remember that guy's name is
beyond me i can't believe him byron
allen byron allen
okay crazy i yeah i never saw this show
let me look this [ __ ] up
comics unleashed you know what that
means that sounds familiar what that
means
you're not a true stand-up you're a
youtuber yeah i'm a youtuber yeah you're
you it is comics unless you're right
wow i still watch it like every saturday
i don't know why i was
[Music]
it wasn't like this it was like this
yeah
guys know that it's titties floppy
knockers yeah the floppy
who wants those nick what the [ __ ] man i
heard that from a guy on uh on a podcast
though
okay i was trying to steal as my own i
thought it would be a great hit but
cindy margolis would have this had this
like late night show where it's a bunch
of
bunch of [ __ ] lucy gooseys with their
titties and their dicks out and they
would just
it was like public television they would
censor [ __ ] but i remember this specific
game that they had
where it's it's like a beach party
everybody's in their bikinis
asses and titties everywhere jack off
city for a 12 year old right mm-hmm
they would have two they would have two
uh dressing rooms with just like fabric
over it and obviously the lights in
there so you could see them undressed
but a guy and a girl would would uh go
into one and they would switch their
clothes so a girl would come out wearing
the guy's bathing suit and she'll cover
up her titties and she wears shorts
okay and he would have to wear her
bikini and they would come out and then
i would jack off a cindy margolis
i don't know that at all and then my dad
would come in he's like what are you
watching and i would turn off the tv
really fast
and i'll be like i wasn't watching
anything and then he would put the hand
to the back of the tv
and it was hot oh and this would take
the heat from the hand that he got from
the tv and smacked me upside my head
do you remember that like that like
there was a little bit of gray on the tv
as soon as you turn it off just just
little floats right there yeah just like
you could still see that it's still on i
used to get in trouble all the time for
the heat
i would watch csi miami that's what i
watched csi new york okay
csi miami and i wasn't allowed to watch
it bro the heat of the tv is like
finding a mur
like a gun crime scene dude like that's
so that's what my mom would do they just
turned
you could always tell when the tv was
just turned off no mama no i didn't say
this dude she was my original white
chocolate sin
let me see i wanna see what this woman
is
this is a greek woman cindy margot she
had tatas this is cindy margolis as a 12
year old
let me see cindy margolis she looks like
nicole arbour dude
for 12. i don't remember her playmate
yeah she looks like she could be like
she's hanging out with you after on the
weekends you know
cinema ago at all that must have is that
public access yeah i didn't know that
[ __ ] you watching dude what kind of [ __ ]
are you watching comics unleashed
the [ __ ] are you talking about i told
you bro i would watch seinfeld and i'll
watch csi dude seinfeld wasn't [ __ ] and
every time friends were still [ __ ]
funny i would
i would turn off friends i would never
watch friends friends was always whack
as [ __ ]
i gotta watch who's lying remember who's
lying who's lying was dope whose line is
it and he was like
hilarious [ __ ] yeah kids will never know
what it's like to watch who's lying
nowadays
who's on was the [ __ ] bro the skinny
dude the skinny giraffe looking dude he
looked like the zebra
ryan what was his name lewis no what was
that yeah ryan lewis
essentially wilding out is like the hood
version of [ __ ] whose line is his
anyways yeah it's like
[ __ ] yeah wayne brady was so [ __ ]
wayne brady was a [ __ ] that guy
freestyle
oh he raps and he sings when he
freestyles it sounds like he wrote the
rhymes in his brain
already you know like that's how good he
is at what he does
do you know what the best thing he ever
did was when he came on the chapel show
oh that was the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] is white
i don't know
the chappelle show was so [ __ ] great
dude
i remember going home after wednesdays
it was on wednesdays at 10
middle school i'd run home and i would
just wait like come on baby come out
it was so fun they were all like all
these skits
were knockout like [ __ ] amazing
everybody would quote
all of chapel like when we were in high
school that was like our [ __ ]
i remember we everybody would be quoting
chappelle non-stop like you couldn't get
away from it like dude
hilarious so funny his stand-up is
[ __ ] he's hilarious
i've seen him live at the laugh factory
i've never i don't think that's
i think that's the hardest i've ever
laughed at myself at a show
but i i it was like unbelievable to me
to see
like i was literally in pain and
everyone else was like
legitimately like like ah like folded
over
like just like oh like like stop like
stop
because like i my cheek like i literally
was my body would you know your pain
[ __ ] come out and i remember looking
around and being like how the
[ __ ] is this you're doing this so like
this powerful like it was it was
unbelievable he said some of the jokes
that are the most obscure [ __ ] this fool
said this joke
about um lil nas x right it's like
little naz
x is dope because he's a he's a gay dude
but he's a rapper
but he owns that [ __ ] and this whole did
like this parodies he did a really quick
parody song a [ __ ] tupac
it was like this [ __ ] comes out
he's like come in me
and hillary
he's just the most obscure [ __ ] bro
he's so good is he called a gay tupac
dude
yeah i remember seeing him on like an
old on hbo they had like def jam comedy
or
and it wasn't it was like a i think it
was def jam i wasn't sure it was like a
some comedy show
it had like him ian edwards had a bunch
of dudes i remember
you seeing ian edwards and i remember
seeing him and he was talking about like
gay
gay pride parades he's like we should
have a straight pride parade or some
[ __ ] and like you like
like about farts like loud farts being
like he's like none of this
[ __ ] like we go something about like how
dudes can't compliment other dudes like
girls do he's like
he's like that we can't do that he's
like damn something that dick vayne is
[ __ ] stronger than a [ __ ]
like don't jump him do a jumping jack
jumping jack bro
it was so i remember i was like 12. i
was like oh my god it's just hilarious
some of these comics man when they have
it they have it there's there's like
girls there's comics too when they have
specials
it doesn't translate yeah it's just
they're better in person it really is
it's way better like even kevin hart
when i watch his specials on tv
on on netflix i'm like it's just not
that great yeah but i watch it
i've watched them live twice dying
laughing yeah it's way different
yeah for some reason it's just way
funnier when you're there it's yeah it's
it's one of those things like
it doesn't translate to spell like when
we saw bill burr his last special was
really [ __ ] good
yeah i remember when we saw him live he
did two hours
like straight fire bro like we were
laughing so [ __ ] hard the whole time
and when we watched
the same material they did live onto the
tv it was just like
well also it wasn't as it and they also
edited it kind of weird and they also
left out a bunch of stuff as well too
but it just doesn't translate as well as
when you're there but also you kind of
knew it was coming like especially it
was the same material but even then it's
like he did it differently
like the way he did it live and the way
he filmed it was a little bit different
but it was different enough to be to a
point where like he would add things
that we didn't hear when he did it live
yeah yeah
and it's still funny but it's also like
man it's just it's a little bit
different
it is meant to be live though because
like you get sucked in you get just
sucked into the
like you're really like when you're in a
movie theater like you're just really in
the [ __ ] and you think about
like comedy shows if you're not there to
laugh what the [ __ ] are you there
exactly
right like people are in the zoo you
ever see some people like
in a comedy show in a comedy show
they'll just sit there
they're probably they're using comics
though no like they're people that are
like
paid like i go there not to laugh but
i don't know i think about every time it
almost ruins the show for me sometimes
because i always look over i'm like this
[ __ ] still didn't laugh
that's crazy yeah i was like and you
know that was hilarious that was funny
as [ __ ]
and they'll just go like this you know
who's not funny live or
on tv brendan's shop this is hard to
watch man i still haven't seen it
his [ __ ] is [ __ ] hard oh i'm never
going to meet him in person i don't give
a [ __ ]
he's your guest next week we actually
i've only seen clips of
like a couple minute clips of the
special and i like was i just turned it
i was like
you know the thing is it's like because
joe rogan co-signs him i want to like
him that's the hard part usually if i
want to like somebody i'll find
something funny yeah
i don't know why i just it's hard but
then i like it listening to him talk
yeah i like him on the podcast
and then i saw him do stand up and it
was just really awkward well i mean you
got to think
total how long has you been doing
stand-up for probably maybe less than
five years right yeah
so it's like that's not a long time to
be doing stand-up
he had a special already which is nuts
but he has the following
with the with the full crowd and people
were laughing and i was like what are
you laughing at
that was not funny it's so crazy like
when you go on youtube
you know how there's like
recommendations right more than
like all the videos i see a brand new
show that pop up on recommendations are
always like
why brendan schaab sucks at comedy like
people oh really relations of like why
and there's a lot of hate
like a lot of people just really don't
don't do this dude man i feel
i feel bad for him it makes me laugh i
feel bad for his million dollars but you
know yeah he's crying in the bank but at
the same time it's like dude
for you to want to do stand-up like
imagine for him like he's always the one
who stand up forever he does stand up
and all these people dedicate their time
to edit a super cut of why he sucks at
comedy
there's not even a terrible it's not
even a super cut you just have to hit
play and then watch it all the way
through
but people make a suit and that's comedy
baby
yeah i mean people spend the time to do
it and it hurts me to say this because i
enjoy
listening to him on like the podcast i
like him too so it's hard
i actually like he seems like a cool
dude to me yeah sure he'll [ __ ] me up
he makes me laugh you forget this full
[ __ ] killer
yeah he was a top 10 [ __ ] heavyweight
yeah yeah big as [ __ ]
i think it's just for him it's just time
more time
you know bro expecting anyone to be a
killer within
five years is crazy how does joe rogan
have a conversation with him about him
ending his fighting career but he won't
do that for comedy for him
like in terms of like hey cause he's
like you're just getting started like
he's like hey you know maybe work on
this isn't that because you're
brainstorming
there's no brain trauma yeah yeah yeah
that's right versus emotional so
what about my brain trauma
yeah there's soul trauma there's
emotional trauma for sure
there's like time trauma because you
wasted it you know you're like oh [ __ ]
i'm never gonna get that
well i mean he's getting paid hard oh
he's doing he's doing fine long time ago
david watching it you know oh yeah yeah
and i'm not saying i'm a better comic
than he is i'm talking about as
a as a viewer you know as a fan it's
like just an objective like viewer fan
like i
i i can laugh at almost anybody's jokes
honestly like i could find the funny and
even if i don't think it's funny i can
see why it's funny
his was hard i was like yo i don't what
the [ __ ] man like you're around
the best comics yeah what the f what the
[ __ ] are you doing dude yeah or maybe
they're not telling them
yeah i and i mean i'm sure they do talk
to him and uh
well i don't actually i don't know but
he knows but i feel like stand-up is one
of those things where you just have to
let the process go right like
you just have to you have to [ __ ]
really suck what are you talking about
you talked
like you think you just rushed it you
think this is what it is he he you okay
like so when you listen to most
like dudes that have been in common even
bill burr like all those dudes on
podcasts they talk about comedy they're
like bro it takes like at least
10 years to like sure even know what's
cracking yeah to even find your voice
yeah to even find your voice to like
even
like i've heard some guys be like it
takes at least five years to even
understand what's going on between you
and the audience yeah
so like i still don't know so because
it's so hard dude like it really is
because you you there's so many factors
to it like it's not just your jokes and
not just
like what you're going to say timing all
the technical stuff but it's like the
way you your end the energy the way you
carry yourself
the crowd themselves adjusting to the
crowd yeah
adjusting to the environment handling
like live heckler
situations or noises or something
awkward that happens like you have to be
on that [ __ ] with the quickness and all
that stuff takes [ __ ] time
perhaps it takes a lot of time and also
not
really like it's a it's one thing to be
like oh i'm not nervous when i get on
stage
but like you're still kind of like it
gets
it takes a long time to really not give
a [ __ ] yeah like to truly like i'm up
there and this me i don't give a [ __ ]
really really give a [ __ ] that takes a
long time i bought my bomb whatever what
happened
yeah like that that like not just saying
that but really feeling that and just
going like a patrice o'neill style where
he's like yo this could i don't care how
this goes
yeah like that is that takes [ __ ]
when you see chappelle like
when he goes up there he looks like he's
just like oh i'm
just talking about this right yeah the
best thing he goes like as a standard
comic he said
half the room is supposed to be dying
laughing and the other half was supposed
to be mortified yeah yeah yeah
you're supposed to be saying something
you're supposed to have an opinion
exactly
exactly
and that's the thing too is like like
that's vulnerable to really especially
if your opinion is kind of crazy yeah
and you know it is
and you're like [ __ ] i'm really taking
this chance you know um everything in
your brain is saying like protect
yourself don't say that don't say or say
it nice or say it nicer yeah there's
just nothing that he's saying that
um i don't get it it's like why why
it's regular observation yeah it's we
don't need you to say that
you know yeah so why is it a joke well
that's what i'm saying like i think i
for him it seems like that's like some
new
comedy [ __ ] and joe rogan too i remember
he said this on a podcast where he was
having a conversation with bob saget
and he was telling bob sagan about how
back in the day when he was in comedy
clubs
there are people who um they were
daytime comics right so they were an
electrician and they read a book about
how to do comedy
and yeah they might get a few chuckles
here and there but they were so adamant
that they're coming i'm like bro you're
talking about your friend brenden shop
right now
we you know and i was like you're
literally talking about brenda's job
right now like he's at that level yeah
but i guess maybe it's because they're
friendship he doesn't see it or i don't
know i'm
i'm sure the i'm the way he probably
looks at it is like this is my homie and
he's just starting comedy and i'm trying
to help him start now
that's why i feel like i feel like joe
rogan was a good thing for him to set
him up but it's also some of the worst
stuff because
because he is now hanging out with
people at a high caliber they expect
that type of comedy out of them maybe
that's why i expect that type of comedy
out of them
but but also like that's if you're going
to learn
that's the best being around those
people is the best way to learn you know
what i mean like he
i think he was even talking about i've
heard him talk about charlie murphy
being like he started comedy like when
he was famous and he had never done
stand-up
and charlie murphy would go out in front
of live like full audiences and bomb
and everyone went into a charlie murphy
stand-up and it was it was
right well that was the thing is because
like you you see him be funny on the
chappelle show and you're like oh this
guy's got it but like
that people don't understand like being
funny on a show like that or in skits
it's different than stand-up like it's a
different art form you know like there's
it's a different skill like it like it's
it takes
charlie murphy to like rest in peace
like one of my best memories on the
chappelle show
so good i saw him live and it was like
jokes that airy spirits makes about him
but when he was doing stand-up i wasn't
sure if he was trying to make me laugh
or he was going to beat me up
it looked like he was going to [ __ ]
somebody up really so i was like
is he mad or is he making jokes yeah
like oh that's charlie murphy yeah
i'm pretty sure if you guys look up some
of his stand up too
the whole time not yelling he just has a
very intimidating vibe
yeah and so when he was doing standing
his eyes just like he's like yeah you
know
he's like yeah back in the day i was
gonna [ __ ] up this [ __ ]
i'm like that's like really good charlie
that's a really good charlie murphy dude
i was like yo where's the joke
i'm sitting there my ass is sweating my
[ __ ] balls
yeah so he would just yeah i don't know
like his standard wasn't my favorite but
he was a great storyteller he was a dude
no doubt about it that dude's [ __ ]
funny
yeah but that's just another example of
like a guy that he started
at the top you know what i mean like he
didn't go like the normal
uh go to open mics grind it out for some
years blah blah he started because he
was already famous and funny
kind of like kramer who was already
famous and i was like i could do this
and then starts dropping n-bombs and
that's [ __ ] that's the worst story
he's there
that's another example of a dude that
that started he was like already famous
funny and was like hey let me just try
this [ __ ] out or like let me get into
this
but like you're like his bombing stories
are way worse because
there there's that ex like you said that
expectation of like this dude's supposed
to be funny what the [ __ ] is this
like when we bomb it's like people who
they don't even know who you the [ __ ]
you are
exactly so they're like okay like he
bombed like that was whack but whatever
exactly and then we can kind of like
slink away in the shadows and be like i
need to figure it out
yeah but those dudes had to like figure
it out in the light the whole [ __ ]
time yeah that's what i'm saying
i feel like the whole joe rogan uh push
that he got
was the best and worst thing that could
happen to him it was the best that he's
gonna make money because now he has a
crowd
yeah but if if he has aspirations of
people considering him to be a great
stand-up comic
he has a harder hill to push up now or
it's just
it's definitely a hard hill yeah no
doubt about it but i mean hey dude if
he's game and and
who knows you know 10 years from now we
might be like brendan shaw figured it
out
yeah i know he might he might not be die
laughing exactly so so it sounds like
you want to challenge
brendan shop to a fight is that true
yeah i know a guy that's organizing a
fight
absolutely not dude that's his match-up
it's brendan [ __ ] [ __ ]
i would [ __ ] my pants i remember when he
knocked out uh freaking
uh [ __ ] left left leg funeral
oh yeah um i cried cop is my favorite
fighter of all time he's the [ __ ] i love
croco and he knocked out mirko cro cop
and i almost died and then gabriel
gonzaga knocked out miracle crocodile oh
that was so good
that
yeah dude no that [ __ ] was oh people
people forget like a british job he
sucked i was like you know he was a top
10 heavyweight he was pretty good bro
he beat some good guys but also like the
times he lost
it was just like he just got outgunned
like it was just like there was that
made a mistake
there was a couple losses he had to
where he was like nogueira like he was
[ __ ] nogara
remember yeah he
his hands were good yeah but people
forget that stuff they're like yeah [ __ ]
brendan schaab would [ __ ] murder you
dude oh yeah
he did a good job of making people
forget that like he was a murderer
yeah you know but yeah i must have
forgotten you remember that roy jones
song
i hope he comes out to that [ __ ] do you
know what james made a rap song
it always starts with you i must have
forgot i forgot and it's like
that's the name of this episode right
here in the game for all the money is it
[ __ ] to come with it y'all must have
forgot y'all must have forgotten that's
just slaps
bro come on who has the best song though
t woodley baby
i'll beat your ass he's gonna fight
colby covington who do you think's gonna
win
what's your prediction i hope i'll tell
you this he
t woodley needs to win yeah he needs to
alex was giving us some insight because
when he was
whoever don't hanging but don't agree
you know what i guess
[Music]
y'all
he's had more than one songs right that
is y'all must have forgot
next up tyler with this i'll beat your
ad i'll beat you
tyron woodley is literally the worst
rapper that has ever existed on the face
of the [ __ ]
i didn't listen to it you you you gotta
look i'm going to
sway in the morning freestyle oh he did
swear in the morning and he prefaces
this he goes no
i'm not a rapper so if y'all gonna climb
me just remember i'ma beat your ass
that's when you know you suck wow he was
he just like got super offbeat started
rambling some random words he was like
yeah
cause we in the cut i'm all okay
yeah so i'm finna come here oh
don't stop with the fists out yup
it was like that it was bad so you know
bad
like bad comedy makes you cringe but
like bad freestyling or rapping
on like a platform like this i guarantee
that makes me feel
that makes me feel anxious saw that meme
if he starts rapping
in the ring he's going to put [ __ ]
kobe comington in a world of hurt
tap out by [ __ ] bad music i hope i
hope he beats
colby by the way ty woodley i'm a huge
fan
we'd love to have you on hey if you
don't want to fight brendan's shop i
know a guy we can match up
you and tyrone he's fighting
next saturday so yeah he'll be free
tonight he'll be all right yeah yeah
whatever tyrant i'll beat you
oh i'll beat your meat
i'll beat your [ __ ] i'm gonna beat your
meat
i'll beat your meat i'll still be
rapping but i'll beat your meat
that's what you'll say that's the
ultimate trump card you win every time
dude yeah
how about that black dot uh freestyling
black dots see
people uh what was that funk man i don't
know but that [ __ ] was punk master
[ __ ] master play grand master [ __ ]
master flex [ __ ] master flex
funk i still listen to that sometimes it
gets me so pumped that [ __ ] she is so
drunk people
forget about how or they just i feel
like he's not in the conversation of
like lyricists and just embassies
he's he's like top five well since we're
talking about freestyling you know we
are highly at the end of this episode
right
i'll beat your ass all right nick oh
here we go
and let me give you a royalty free beach
hit them with it
i'm gonna do some smooth [ __ ] we'll do
uh what lo-fi hip-hop just to give it
so you put everyone asleep yeah i want
you to do a low-fi
hip-hop freestyle jazzy oh [ __ ]
oh god that's not it yeah shadow legend
we're talking abs by the way bro they're
getting more obnoxious they always had
like the ugliest dude on the heels have
you guys ever heard of this game before
yes i'm lisley yeah yeah you get all the
game ones huh
okay nick here we go um nico last night
oh oh there's a nice beat i'm feeling
that
surprisingly that's the feeling like
rain drops in the background you know
what i mean
okay turn me up on that headset real
quick okay here we go it's all the way
up a little more snare please
oh what my name is
my name is there's no more my name is
nick okay
give him a subject uh talk about
elephants dude
elephants elephants elephants are my
favorite
my favorite animals i have ears like my
fa uh
you don't [ __ ] rap we'll be here for
another hour dude dude we're gonna be
here for another hour
hit it give pat a subject we're shocked
uh t-shirts
t-shirts oh pat's gonna kill it watching
that fire actually how about we're
talking pink raw meat
go ahead you've already [ __ ] it up
dude
pink raw meat we're talking about it's
raw pink we
ain't talking about kabuki oh i'm gonna
go to the bathroom and take a little
dookie
it's fire well that wraps up this
episode of the genius brain podcast
remember raw pink beat ain't talking
about kabuki come on
baby and i take a big dookie wow
lyricist of
first generation
he tatum like a boxer he's a basketball
player actually we used to box him
he was tall he was like six six in like
[ __ ]
sophomore year and it was so hard like
talk about range like we were like i was
five
foot trying to hit this dude he would
[ __ ] crack me like doll scene from
across the room
he'd beat everybody's ass dude fire he
was like
and his rap his lyrics were fire raw
pink meat ain't talking about kabuki
boom still saying her in the ass they
get straight up in her booty
oh i do it quick because that's my
duty what next line please
um my friend's david sow and he's he's a
real big foodie
that's good i don't get to offer that
that's good bro
i came up with that on the top you
should do stand-up bro
because that's the exact sound of
somebody who's bombing on stage yeah
yeah
for us it is just like us when we were
kids i'm used to it i think i could bomb
pretty well i'll probably the top five
bomber yeah
well guess what guys you can find
patrick t riley on instagram and
everything else like that who knows man
maybe genius brain might have to go on
the road and get these [ __ ] stand up
breasts off the [ __ ] screws and
buckets you know what i'm saying screws
and buckets
i'm just making a random [ __ ] that's
what people say we're getting the rust
off the scrolls and buckets the fire's
really affecting us right now
yes it is it's very smoky patrick t dot
ryland you can find nick dunn
at nick the ear find him for all of your
goods and all of your toiletry needs all
your kirkland brand
all your kirkland brand stuff he has
siphoned away all the sanitary stuff
from kirkland and
he's selling it on the streets yep
excretes out of the the trunk of my
miata
yep we'll see you all next time